hey Vsauce Michael here and a couple of
weeks ago vices new channel noisy
blindfolded me the Gregory Brothers
about 200 other people and then bust us
to a hidden Skrillex show it was cool
but what is I mean what does it mean to
be cool cool as a judgment of taste
people who are cool are with it they
exhibit a style that people want to
emulate they're fashionable but being
cool isn't just about confidence or
being above the situation in fact what
is considered cool changes all the time
here's a fantastic illustration charting
by time and location what was generally
considered cool to truly get to the
origin of what we today mean by cool
we're gonna have to go back to West
Africa in the 15th century the Yoruba
language has a great word it - - it
means physical beauty but also being
calm and detached from your
circumstances
almost unnaturally so in a superhuman
kind of way and a similar but more
specific term comes from the Italian
concept of spread cetera this was a way
of behaving favoured by the wealthy
upper class in 15th century Italy and to
exhibit this behavior you wanted to act
nonchalant even if doing so would take a
lot of work you would hide your desires
and emotions behind ironic detachment
but where can you see spread satura well
how about here the Mona Lisa she doesn't
laugh she's exercising restraint it
almost feels like she's looking down on
you smuggling now to make this more
clear let's take a look at a recent
discovery a painting that used to be
thought of as a copy of the Mona Lisa
made years and years later except recent
restoration has shown that the very same
mistakes and corrections that da Vinci
made on the
original were also done on this painting
leading restores to believe that this
painting was made side by side with the
actual Mona Lisa look at her expression
it's even more clear that she's looking
at you like huh really you think you're
cool okay
related is the Italian concept of omertà
this is keeping your cool and not
telling the authorities anything about
anybody it's the type of attitude you
see in movies like Goodfellas or The
Godfather but our modern definition of
cool may most directly come from slaves
and prisoners people in those positions
are subjected to Authority in a very
direct way and any kind of rebellion
against Authority or fighting against it
is most certainly going to be answered
with nothing but punishment a very
little chance of success and so instead
an attitude of ironic detachment is
taken on which allows you to distance
yourself from that Authority to be away
from it against it without actively
confronting it and getting in trouble
now later on in the 1940s the actual
word cool began to stick to this
attitude it came out of the smoke-filled
nightclubs where jazz beatnik and
bohemian culture thrived the only way to
freshen up that smoke-filled air was to
open windows and let the cool night air
in saxophonists Lester Young is credited
with making this connection and
popularizing the use of the word cool
even cooler is the fact that Lester also
popularized the use of the word red to
mean money we'll look at that the Sun
has come out that's cool it also means
it's a good time to talk about the brain
Laurent Steinberg points out that there
are systems in the brain that mature as
we get older the first is the
socio-emotional Network and this deals
with social and emotional implement the
second is the cognitive control Network
this deals with regulating behavior and
making ultimate decisions but these two
networks do not mature at this
rate in fact there's an awkward period
in puberty and adolescence where the
social-emotional network in our brain is
more active and so whether or not people
think you are cool matters more to you
than is reasonable so in a way you could
say that the less worried you are with
being cool the more developed your brain
is instead focus on vocabulary the only
thing that doesn't change the only
coolness that doesn't fade is cool the
word over the years we have used all
kinds of other words to mean cool but
the one that has never changed the one
that has always been cool to use is cool
and that's cool go check out that
Skrillex concert footage noisy is the
channel that uploaded that new m.i.a
video as well as mi a's responses to
youtube comments and according to this
guy fat people shouldn't be making music
all I know is as always thanks for
watching
[Music]